say congratulations on the engagement
thank you are you in wedding planning
mode right now I've had no time to plan
a wedding I don't know I'm torn out to
write I don't know how people do it I'm
like I've got a pig pooping around the
house I've got four dogs I've got a
heart like the fire it's been so crazy
and I'm working on a new special which
is basically like planning a wedding you
have to pick a venue you have to get
your pit you know my poor fiancé it's
just like he's probably thrilled that
it's not moving too quickly I have not
had time to be a bridezilla yet and but
I'm looking at venues because I'm
touring so much so every plate city I go
around the country I like I was just in
Utah and I looked at a venue there do
you know of three wedding must-haves
that you do want to have three wedding
must have swore a dress I hear you need
to have a dress what kind of dress are
you gonna go like tight princess I
aren't you I need you can you help you
the fact that you even know what you're
talking about kids I was like picking on
a dress and then my girlfriend's like no
you have to pick out a venue and then
you have to pick out a dress that
matches the venue and I was like I
didn't even think of that so I
personally need you I need you that's
another essential I've no idea what I'm
doing I guess I need a venue a dress the
venue and a lot of alcohol and food that
would help people drinking a lot of
alcohol totally so I'm kind of just I'm
navigating this whole thing right now I
really want to do my wedding at a place
that's like a sanctuary or rescue to
sort of help draw attention to one so
there's one called blue sky in Utah and
there's bestfriends which is in Zion in
Utah so I'm thing about doing in a place
like that so that everyone can like tag
it and post it and spread awareness
about a rescue that might need some
attention well the animals be in the
wedding I mean my my birthday it's gonna
have to deal with me walking down the
aisle with nine horses like good queen
and the pig needs to be the ring bear
the pig I'm marrying the pic my fiance
is the ring bearer and I'm marrying the
pig talk to me about being here you're
co-hosting tonight with Hilary Duff I
know what they do is incredible work
here why do you love it so much you know
um it's pretty simple I wish I had a
super interesting answer but you know of
all the animal rescue groups this is one
that's just really shown up and been
incredibly consistent and brave and
really goes to the root of the problem
not just you know we all want to it's a
little bit easier sometimes to put
band-aids on it and you know the more I
learn about animal rescue I'm still
learning a lot is that you know the best
thing the most effective thing to do is
try to get to the root of the problem
spaying neutering so that we won't be in
this situation where we have millions of
dogs in shelters education Sasha who
runs it it's just um so tireless she is
she is brave she is inexhaustible you
really know exactly where your money is
going she is not in it for the glory or
the hero complex I've met her at
hospitals where she's just in pajamas
with a freakin one-legged dog with no
eyeballs and she you know with one year
left and she's still just fighting for
this dog and doing whatever she can you
know and I'm inspired by her and so
anytime she calls I'm I come I'm like a
junkie when did you first realize your
love for animals they're like a good
story there you know I wish I had a good
story it's gonna be wrapped up in
sadness and I don't want to bum anybody
out but growing up I was just alone a
lot you know which is a good thing on
some level my mother worked very hard
which set an example that women can work
and be busy which is a good thing but I
was alone a lot and animals were just
kind of my friends have kids you know
and I was out a little socially awkward
I was never great with like people but I
was like great with animals they know
they don't talk back they don't
challenge you they don't judge you they
love you unconditionally and as I got
older I started doing at Point therapy
with horses and working with a bunch of
groups that do that and I just started
learning how healing animals can be you
know they are the you know I think
medicine that doesn't have really any
side effects
[Music]
[Applause]